in this book we have many many dragons
and many many Valyrian steel swords and
if you could have if you could ride one
dragon and wield one sword which would
it be well if I could write on one
dragon I might as well go with the
biggest which would be balerion the
black dread he's he's the mega dragon in
in this early book he's the the only one
that remembers of valaria past a certain
point as he was brought over from
malaria at a little before the doom of
Valyria and he's the biggest and meanest
of the dragons that exists if I could
wield only one sword I don't think it
would be any of the Targaryen swords it
would be dawn the swords the sword
wielded by the sword of the morning the
air of house Dayne of Starfall which is
made from the metal from a fallen star
and who knows what magical property is
falling stars bring to earth there's a
question here from again from somebody I
think who may be in the orders from
crystal Phillips who says are there any
scenes in A Song of Ice and Fire that
you look back on and smile because they
were just so much fun to write I mean
that sounds like one but it's not in a
sum of ice and fire are there any that
you you know you mentioned that the the
first scene with bran are there any that
really just get you would give you a
tingle when you look back on them um
there are certainly scenes that I that I
remember but they tend not to be the
ones that are fun to write they tend to
be happy the ones they're painful to
write I mean the hardest thing I ever
wrote was the red wedding scene and in a
storm of sorts and I knew that was
coming I was enough of a architect there
that I was I was building toward that
scene I've been building therefore that
scene since the first book but when I
actually reached that saying it was too
painful to write I couldn't write it I
skipped over it I should say it occurs
about two-thirds of the way through
Storm of Swords I skipped over it and I
wrote the scenes that follow
I finished the entire book
and I hadn't written that scene yet that
was the last thing I wrote for Storm of
Swords I had to go back and make myself
write it and it still emotionally you
become very attached to these characters
believe it or not I don't have the
reputation for gleefully killing some of
them but that's not entirely deserved
sometimes it's very painful for me to
kill them they're there you know my
children for good or ill so that was a
tough scene to write
I do periodically enjoy you know if I
write something that I'm particularly
proud of that really is that I think is
a good piece of writing that is vivid
and evocative then that gives me
pleasure but it might not necessarily be
the scenes that that you guys would
particularly enjoy some of them were
just quiet things about oh I have to
describe this landscape and I sweat and
we write it and rewrite it and I finally
give you this is a great description of
three guys riding through a grassy
meadow I've gotten the sights and the
sounds and the smells of the scene right
- to put you there but it's not
necessarily anything that ordinary
readers or reviewers who ever oh my god
there was such a beautiful description
of the grassy meadow on page 314 so but
this is a question from Adrian Modelo
who says how is your work space
organized to write a song of ice and
fire do you have a corkboard like in
police investigations where you've noted
all the targaryen x' and the and all the
phrase vs. Adrian give us a physical
sense of how you write and where you
write well I I don't have a corkboard
I have maps now web is there's been a
beautiful map book called the lands of
Ice and Fire so I printed out those
large scale maps and I keep them around
me so I can refer it to the maps from
time to time most of the stuff is
actually in my head I do have computer
files you know with timelines on them
and
that I've put together over the years
and bits of this and bits of that that I
can consult from time again it is
sometimes a daunting task more so
nowadays than when I began back in 1991
because the world has become so much
bigger and has become so much more
complex and in many ways I followed the
template of Tolkien you know if you look
at Lord of the Rings everything begins
in the Shire and with the with the
hobbits and then as they leave the Shire
they they get to Rivendell and they meet
some more people they pick up Strider
they pick up the rest of the Fellowship
but then from that point they start to
split off first they split into two
groups and then the two groups put into
three groups and etc well I followed
more or less the same map I mean if you
if you look at Game of Thrones
everybody except Danny is together in
Winterfell in the beginning all the
viewpoint characters there and but then
they start splitting and Danny is still
off by herself on another continent but
you know some of my people go to King's
Landing some of them stay in in
Winterfell and then the people go to
sick King's Landing get separated from
each other and they go and different and
every time a character goes off on a
different tangent they meet other
supporting characters so at this point
I'm really writing not a novel but
twelve intertwined novels and each
character has is in a different place
with their own antagonists their own
friends their own secondary and tertiary
surrounding them and yes that is very
difficult to keep in my head I maybe
should have organized a little better
when I began back in 1991 but I never
thought it would get to that I mean
remember I'd written I'd written four
novels before this Armageddon rag fever
dream went Haven with Lisa total dying
at a light I never had any problems
keeping those characters in my head I
didn't think corkboards or anything I
just remembered it all I had no idea
though that when I got into this that
the size the
that it would eventually become
unfortunately you know we it's the age
of computers we have search and replace
functions and I I can I can load up you
know my my gigantic file and said okay
what what did I ever say about this
character and I go through even though I
make mistakes as and my fans like you
people and even more obsessive people
elsewhere are always eager to point out
whenever I've made a mistake
i i have particular trouble with the
color of people's eyes and and rather
famously I have a horse who changes
gender between the first and second
books it's I I don't have it's hard to
do a search and replace for the sex of a
horse so but you know these these errors
do they're sneaking do you ever find
you've pet you sort of painted yourself
into a corner and you've set up a part
of the world that then impedes your
story tone yeah that is the disadvantage
of being a gardener
you know the architect never finds
himself building closed rooms that go
nowhere but the gardener sometimes
traipse down the branch and finds
himself sitting all the way at the out
at the end realizing he can't get from
that branch anywhere else so sometimes I
do go down byways and say no I think I
took the wrong turn back like three
chapters ago let me rewrite these
chapters or in one case or remove these
chapters I never destroy them I keep
them on my computer in case I see a way
to put them in later there's always that
there's rather famously from from the
last book that was published as with
dragons I had a chapter where Tyrion was
was moving down the river river rowing
and the shy made and and
I wrote this chapter where he meets a
character called the shrouded Lord and
it's a it's a really good chapter I mean
I like some chapters more than others
this is a terrific chapter but it it's
an absolute dead end admitted what
office the dead end but it introduces
like three additional layers of
complication that I didn't think I
actually needed but I liked it so much I
kept trying to fit it in you know at
first I presented it straight and then I
said oh I can't fit it now presented as
a dream Tyrion has a dream and he dreams
that this happened to him and it has
portents and then I splitted all them
into like eight dreams and every tyrion
chapter he dreamed a little bit of it
and and finally I gave up and said I
can't I have to rip out all this stuff
it doesn't it doesn't do me any good
someday maybe I have when I finished a
whole book I'll publish that that lost
chapter is a little stand alone
[Laughter]